hey how are you doing
i'm doing great thanks for asking
what's the weather like cloudy with a
chance of rain
that sounds very boring it's not boring
it's just not as fun what do you think
of this current chatbot
i think they were all right
what is a chap lot a lot of chat
welcome everybody to another centex
tankers episode
where we left off we were conversing
with our chat bot here
and he was just about to say that
anyway uh yeah so where we left off we
are able to talk
to our chat bot and get responses back
but actually what we want to do is get
audio responses back in the form of text
to speech
so uh that's what we're going to be
working working on in this video and
hopefully it won't take us
too too long because we actually already
know kind of how we're going to do it
we're going to use jarvis to do the text
to speech
um i will just throw in again there's
only one
version of there's only one like voice
in this jarvis text-to-speech
so you know in time i would like to use
other voices and i am kind of still
looking around i know there's like
google text to speech
and with that uh the thing i like about
google texas speech is it's like
lightning fast
uh there's a couple other ones i can't
remember all the names and then there's
like mozilla text-to-speech and mozilla
is literally like it let it has
everything you could ever need for
like training text-to-speech models so
i'll also probably look into that and my
expectation is that anything that runs
on the gpu is highly like as long as you
can run it on the gpu
uh it's going to be very fast so um
anyway yeah that's what we um what i'll
probably do in the future but for now
we'll just use the jarvis version
so with that uh let's go ahead and
um i think this is from before let me
get rid of that
and move this okay great uh
so what we're gonna do is
um i think i'm gonna make a copy of this
i am going to rename this and i'm going
to call it just two
tts out i don't know just something
just in case we get lost and we need to
revert back to the original
so then getting back to our original
jarvis files
talk tran i guess we'll maybe talk is
what we want let's see
so in order to actually speak i think
we'll
like we use this args output i think
output is just for a file output file
till
yeah and we don't need to output to a
file we literally just want to hear it
um also this is gonna so probably cause
a slight issue because i'm recording
like when i've because as i'm recording
is gonna come out of the speakers it's
gonna go into the mic and i bet it's
gonna loop
maybe i'll i think i can turn on
when this hopefully i'll remember i'll
turn on desktop audio that's how i'm
going to do it
thanks for helping me guys okay so all
we need
is probably to set
this here and how did we set i'm going
to close this before we get
in trouble how did we set
we do take server here
and then where did we actually where
were we
communicating
hello yeah so i think what we could do
probably is tts going we could probably
do
these uh i'm gonna move this over
actually i think into a separate like
i'm just gonna put it here
hopefully you can still see enough of
that uh we want to
bring in this stuff so we already have
uh jarvis
audio uh we don't have tts
or oh we do have the server so really we
just need to bring in tts
and then wave it looks like so
so there's tts we'll bring in
wave cool
so i think that's everything we need
there um
we also need this like uh this voice
choice probably
so i'm just going to throw this in it's
just going to default to lj speech
um i don't as far as i know there are no
other voices available
at the at the moment i hope they add
more um
so then let's see
so where are we using args dot
server at the moment inside of main
and then it does this so inside of main
i think here i'm just making space so i
can easily find this
if and when this doesn't work so so in
there
we're gonna take it like all of this
here
uh copy paste we already have
this i don't so then we don't need
channel anymore
um tts client is fine
and this doesn't have a repeat so
actually we just needed those two things
um
and then scrolling down to here it looks
like okay this is how you specify
what i guess this is like what a request
is
and then as time goes on we'll just
replace rec.text
the sample rate
will be picked up here i suppose
stream open stream right
the hard part the thing that's giving me
a hard time is
where is where does like this come where
does it actually come out
i'm guessing maybe here maybe when you
do tts
client synthesize uh maybe that
um maybe that's what generates the audio
i'm just taking a guess here what's the
worst that could happen
like people ask me all the time like
these questions like on tutorials and
stuff they're like what would happen if
i change this variable to this and like
like you could have just found out in
the time that it took for you to ask
like it would be quicker um okay so i
think
we have that and then we pop down here
to listen print loop and that's
gotta be again where we're gonna do all
of our stuff
so here output
darn it
for let's i'm trying to decide because
we don't really want to say dialog gpt
every time it outputs anything
so tokenizer decode so really it's just
this so
let's do right output
um let's just say like i don't know tts
uh out will be equal to that
i hope uh tokenizer.code my expectation
is that this would be a string already
but let's just go ahead and
be certain and then uh what we're gonna
do
well we haven't defined the wreck yet uh
the request rather
um boy i'm not sure where i want to do
that
there's probably a better spot to put
this but i'm gonna put it all right here
[Laughter]
uh okay and then all that happens
like i'm not sure what stream got right
like
i really don't know because really
because you would think
like okay you would probably only write
if
arg's output but this is outside of that
if so i kind of think we want
to include the stream and in fact
we probably yeah maybe what we should do
is treat this loop here
that way again syntax organization
technique
uh okay so we have that request here
we probably need to open the stream like
this
boom uh
okay now we'll take
all of this and in a moment we'll get
rid of the args output
so we'll come down here paste
what if we can be done within eight
minutes that'll be awesome if we can
just
boom bang this thing out okay
uh we don't need this and then wreck
text becomes tts out
i don't think we need this
i don't think we need this
i don't well we'll leave that and in
fact let's encase that
in yellow
uh we don't want that stream.right oh we
need
probably how we close where where did
there it is um although
we're never going to hit that because
we're going to control c
so we probably will never i can't think
of a time where we're gonna hit it
but is that right
yeah okay
let's see if that works
uh it always makes me happy to just be
super hacky
uh let's see do i already have yes
okay so let's go ahead and python three
two uh and then we need server
is dgx a100 omg
[Music]
please work no syntax error yet that's
good
oh how are we going to do this i think
we'll just see what happens first and
then i'll have to like speak
mute turn on desktop audio
what oh did we have a different it was
probably a different serve i think i got
screwed up on that
hold on let's see yeah we had the asr
server but not the tts server that's
i my bad copy that
come over here paste bring
back this and
i think i'll turn on let me turn on
desktop audio before i forget
okay i hope this works
i want it to work so bad
why um i guess it's because
um we can use the args in here
right because we've defined them here
but we
where is this i'm getting so lost at
this point
wait where are we where what was that
where was that here
what line are we on man uh 248 and then
133 for rec.voice name
right here where are you okay
uh i'm just gonna hard code it for now
um
it'll be easy uh it's just lj's speech
done done
now
audio handle
audio handle not defined
okay wait it's this
um are we gonna i guess we can just
throw all this into um
i just want this to work uh i don't want
to deal with all this
nonsense yeah i'm just going to cut
i'm going to toss it up here
and then let's see channel
oh gosh are we gonna really do this are
we gonna
hmm yeah how do we want to do this
this is getting dirty this is getting
really dirty but
i just want it to work right again these
are
just scentx tankers this is not final
product
a100 omg um i'm totally
gonna fix this later
um okay
again hey what's going on
i'm so close i'm just i'm so close and
this this
this stuff is just messing with me and
oh you know the thing is
i removed the whole i didn't care like
how long it was taking
um so start time.time stop
i it is interesting how fast the
the texas speech generates i am actually
kind of curious
i think we will leave that
and uh let's go
and we'll import time
okay come on
it's gotta work now it has to work now
now
up what are we doing what is this
hey how are you doing
i'm doing great thanks for asking
what's the weather like cloudy with a
chance of rain
that sounds very boring it's not
boring it's just not as fun
what do you think of this current
chatbot
i think they were all right
what is a chap lot of chat
very interesting very interesting indeed
i'm glad you liked it i did
i did what you did what
i think he means he did the same thing
as the other guy
i think he means he did the same thing
as the other guy
i think he means the same thing as the
other guy
i think he means the same thing that's
the other gut is the one that's the same
as the one on the left
i think he means the same thing what
do you enjoy talking to yourself i do
do you learn anything interesting about
yourself
i learned that i'm not a loser
very interesting how do you know that
i've been to the same place
i'm not sure what you mean by that do
you like any movies
i like a lot of movies i like a lot of
to
shows i like a lot of music
i like a lot of things
what's your favorite type of music
i like a lot of different genres i like
a lot of different genres
alright well i've got to go see you
later see ya
uh i hope i got my uh mute and unmute
working correctly there um yeah so that
was really interesting
um cool i mean i i don't really know
uh what more from here i mean this is a
bot that now
you can literally talk to it talks back
to you over the mic
um to be a little more seamless i'd
probably use like
headphones or something like that um
and then maybe when it's talking have
some sort of flag that disables the
microphone
input i think that's pr that's probably
the way you would do it is whenever
the chat bot is talking yeah i think
that's what i would do
um i don't think i'm gonna do that in
this video
um but anyway uh cool
i just think it's so cool how quickly i
have been able to
develop a chatbot that you talk to it
talks back to you
um and how fast it is right i mean it's
just incredible
how far the technology has come i mean
to think about doing this like
three years ago or four years ago no way
no way and now it's like it it works
really well and it's like instant i mean
that was really that was a pretty fluid
conversation other than me having to hit
my mute button
so the microphone doesn't pick it up so
uh anyway yeah that's really cool that's
really exciting
um i hope you guys have enjoyed i think
i'm gonna leave it here for now there
might be some tweaks that i make and
maybe i'll do another video as i make
more
more and more tweaks to this um but yeah
that's really cool it's really exciting
i can see a lot of applications for this
and then uh i think i'd like to bring it
into discord
so so people could talk to it in discord
like in the voice servers i think that
would be really cool
so anyway uh that's all for now
questions comments concerns whatever
feel free to leave them below otherwise
i will see you guys
in another video
you